materials supplied by Microsoft
Corporation may be used for internal
review analysis or research only any
editing reproduction publication
reproduction internet or public display
is forbidden and may violate copyright
law
hi everyone thank you for coming today
we're gonna have professor Torsten
hofler present some of his work so
Torsten has been a professor at UIUC and
now he's a professor at ETH Zurich he's
visiting the quantum group here in in
Microsoft and he works primarily on
parallel computing performance and he
has published over 200 papers of just
quite impressive Donald had pointed me
to Torsten and I haven't been aware of
his work so you know it sounds very
interesting so I'm looking forward to
learning about his work today
thank you very good thank you very much
yes I'm from ETH and I've been here two
months and this is actually today my
last day as a visiting researcher but
it's likely I will come back so if you
want to talk to me then either catch me
right after the talk or or later this is
in fact work that has been done with
many people most almost centrally my
student much he has contributed to the
the development of the slim fly topology
that I will be talking about at the
beginning I want to give a quick
overview of network topologies in
general what the development was but let
me start with a quick statement about
data centers and Microsoft was operating
a pretty sizable data center business
and and it seems to be moving further
into the the center central attention of
the company as we're all observing and
there are some observations we can make
about data centers so first Google some
people from Google so Dennis ups he
actually observed in this in this paper
down here that about up to 50 percent of
the energy consumption of a data center
could be somewhere related to the
networking infrastructure so these are
various components in the networking
infrastructure and other things and
furthermore there so there's another
work that actually it calculates that up
to 33 percent of a network 33 percent of
a data center cost could be the
networking components so this is
something we have to see whether the
grain of salt because of course that
varies and the exact setting so I
believe there is a very large span I
would say here it's somewhere between
20% and these 50 percent and feels like
a very high and then a 33% that could
also be lower but it could also be
higher so that really depends on how
well your data center is connect
but if you look at the past of this data
center networks what what happened there
I mean what happens from the early 1980s
until today this is something we built
on so I want to quickly explain what was
the kind of the the history here and in
the early days data center topologies or
at this time like computer topology so
nobody talked about data centers in the
early 1980s that term wasn't probably
even coined these early topologies were
mainly restricted by the amount of
silicon available on a single chip so
what that meant they had to have a very
small radix so when I draw these these
graphs here you just read them like a
normal graph and and every every vertex
is a switch and the network and every
line is the connection so a cable in the
network and what we can see here is that
for this particular matter for network
topology we choose a dimensionality of
the network for in this case it's two
and then the radix or the number of
ports for switch we need to support this
for all right so that's extremely simple
it's very very simple to construct this
is actually the main reason why these
networks have survived for so long in
fact if you pump this up a little bit if
you go to three or four or five
dimensional touré you can get a rather
reasonable network but of course the
radix is growing but there are two
problems with this network and these are
actually the two fundamental parameters
we care about we care about in
networking one is the latency and the
other one is the bandwidth so with
latency and we really mean the distance
traveling from one vertex to another the
maximum distance here is somehow the
dthe root of the total number of
vertices and the network so that's bad
so that's actually very bad and the
bandwidth is even worse because you can
cut this network very easily by removing
links from the network so so the global
bandwidth I'm talking about here that's
relatively bad in this tavern
nevertheless since they're very easy to
construct many HPC networks so high
performance computing networks have used
that topology to scale very far because
people call this networks scalable or
this topology because you can just add
more rows and more columns in your in
your particular topology and if you want
to build a very large computer and
that's a very good thing by the way
there is a fundamental disagreement
between me and the rest of the world or
the rest of the networking architects
when we talk about scalability
I do not consider this network as
scalable so by scalability when I say
that term I mean that the bandwidth
scales
and the latency scales as we add more
vertices to a network in the sense this
network is not scalable however
everybody every network architect when
the network architect says scalable
they usually mean oh we can add more
stuff to it and it's relatively easy to
rewire the network and and in that
definition it is scalable so what
happened then well this was of course
discussed and and discovered so then we
went to hypercube style networks and
there the benefit is that we could
actually have a logarithmic latency you
so that's very good and a full bandwidth
so now we have n divided by 2 and we got
rid of the square root term so we
essentially have enough bandwidth that
half of the nodes can to talk to the
other half of the nodes without any
congestion in the network and not just
the square root of those of course the
network radix is no logarithmic though
so that is fundamentally limiting your
size of the network you could have at
the end because you will still need to
build a switch with n ports and then you
can only have 2 to the N endpoints and n
was very small at that time so what
people developed let's well the first
idea to use were Bria well and it's a
brief idea or a tree network so people
just looked at trees and this is what
many data centers look still look today
at the kind of the last generation data
centers look like tree networks so you
mean here yeah so the latency is really
the maximum distance actually the
distance of a shortest path from any
vertex to any other vertex in the
network so here in this case it's it's a
log base 2 n right so if you have n
vertices the maximum distance which is
the shortest path between the maximum
separate two vertices is log base 2 n
then it's the shortest path between any
vertices right and then the bandwidth is
really the how much bandwidth can I
carry through the network in terms of n
all right so if I'm if I'm for example
have a simple all tall pattern everybody
sends to everybody else how much
bandwidth can the network except in that
case so you want this to be n right so
and and in the previous one this was
somewhat square root n to the D so very
low we want this to be n then this is
here in this case this is perfect
because we were
very close to Sammy and the radix is
basically your technology parameter how
large of a switch you need to build in
order to support that network topology
this is just a hypercube so this is yeah
I guess I don't know where the switches
here
well the switches the vertex right okay
so it's like the number of edges leaving
imperfects that's the radius exactly and
as you grow the hypercube you will have
more neighbors
I mean you will every dimension you add
to the hypercube you will double the
number of neighbors and this is why you
have the logarithmic impact here okay
cool
so and then we have this tree Network
and everybody knows the tree right the
bandwidth is one because we all need to
go through the root so that's bad and
the latency is to log in because we need
to go up and down all right so because a
tree as logarithmic definite the radix
is two because we have only two
neighbors should probably started with
this one from an educational perspective
because that's definitely the easiest
one however this is not how people build
these trees because usually in in a data
center context we have a so called top
of the rack switches and then we have
backbone switches in the sense that the
network technology used for the info
implementing these cables gets usually
beefier towards the root and has just a
higher bandwidth right in the hpc or
actually in modern technologies we don't
really do this because we want to have
the fastest connection to the endpoint
so if we already take our fastest
connection to the endpoint we don't have
any any anything else to do to the top
so we just have that link speed that we
want to get to the endpoint okay so
under that assumption what was developed
that was actually developed quite early
on this this is the so called class
network or fat tree network they're not
isomorphic but very very very close so
we can discuss the differences but
they're usually minor so this is a class
network this is a factory network this
is a folded class network but they they
all have the same principle the idea is
that they have a fixed radix and then
they grow multiple layers with this
fixed radix which gives us a two log and
latency right and and that also gives us
a full bandwidth in that particular case
so that's somewhat the dream topology
and in fact this is the topology that is
used for most of the in
relations of large supercomputer systems
today it is used in many modern data
centers today as well so that's kind of
the the default topology however in this
talk I will tell you how to actually
build a topology with very similar
properties but has half the cost it's
because we still want to fight constants
as I'm Tata CLE this topology is optimal
if you don't care about constants but of
course in real life if you actually
invest a couple of hundred million into
a data center then you care about a
constant of two I hope most people do
and then there is this fancy colored
topology that is in fact the graph and
now we're going to talk a little more
about graphs we were abstracting this
away from from the actual technology
whatever we implement these switches
with and that was used in the HPC
context that is a directed graph so all
graphs before were undirected this is
now directed graph so we could kind of
need directed cables I have not seen
directed cables before but that was
constructed for this and it's
technologically feasible was constructed
for this particular machine the
psychotics machine unfortunately the the
startup company went belly-up pretty
quickly after they after they developed
this parts of the reason they said well
parts of the reason could be that this
was incredibly complex network to route
and actually to understand but but we
will see the nice thing here is that
this is actually hitting a lower bound
so so this is nearly strictly optimal so
if we go now from the 1980s to 2005 this
is the quick summary I just gave you
but at that area and around that time
two fundamental changes happened in the
networking business so one fundamental
change is that we went from copper
cables to fiber enabled cables at that
time suddenly fiber became affordable it
was around for a long time but it became
a mass-market product
what does fiber change in the business
fiber changes that we actually can go
long-distance so suddenly we are not
bound by my locality constraints anymore
these copper cables if you know there
are only five meters long if you run
them at a high frequency the fiber
cables they're a kilometer long and
basically you can you can wire your data
center twice in a row and still have a
single cable so that's perfectly fine
let us change number one we enabled long
cables change number two is that we went
from small radix switches to high radix
witches and that's just simply following
Moore's law we have more transistors
available on the chip stability switches
and then we could just build switches
with larger radius
ray disease right so we we went from
these four ports which is to today
easily 100 port switches on a single
chip right that's it that's extremely
important both these developments -
taken together led to the development of
the dragonfly topology which there were
two competing designs I was part of one
design so one design actually survived
the other one didn't of course I was
betting on the wrong horse so I was
working with IBM and the so called percs
topology a wonderful idea there was only
one machine built and I'm not allowed to
talk about this okay has a very one
large scale machine build and I'm not
allowed to talk about this however a
very similar topology was was used by
Craig to build the cascade style area
style network that is where we currently
have the largest installation in
Switzerland with about 5,000 and no it's
running that particular topology and the
idea here is that we have groups that
are fully connected so we see five
groups here and then these groups form
so-called super switches or super groups
that themselves are again fully
connected so it's a two layer fully
connected Network typically we use
electrical connections within the group
and optical connections outside of the
group that was the idea that's a network
that came from engineering constraints
and here we get again an approximately
full bandwidth so we're losing a factor
of two here I can talk about it's not
too bad to lose this factor of two in
fact and we get a fixed latency so three
to five that also means that our maximum
size of the network is limited all right
so the maximum size of a cascade system
that you can buy from Cray is about
65,000 notes same for the perks topology
you we can't buy more with those
switches however that's enough for many
installations and there's also a fixed
radix now that we are talking about but
now if you take this um we we take we
took all the experience we made with
that topology the all the previous
topologies were kind of designed with a
technology in mind so so were ingenious
engineers sitting there and trying to
understand how to use the new technology
constraints in order to build the next
network topology what we did as
scientists so I was always working with
engineers because I really enjoy working
with engineers but we have a slightly
different viewpoints so what we did is
we said okay let's take this to the
extreme let's just assume we have on all
fiber network because fiber is
relatively cheap today if you choose the
right transceivers and let's assume we
we want to build the cheapest possible
network and what I mean by cheap is we
want to have a full bandwidth so
bandwidth of a proportional to n and we
want to have the lowest possible agency
and the lowest possible radix at that
time so what happened then and we use
mathematical optimization property
principles to achieve this so this is
VDD the key here but what we found is
that actually if we drive this
optimization all we need to care about
is the diameter it took me quite a while
to understand this but it but after all
it's really really intuitive if you have
a network where you run your traffic
through and you have basically all - all
communication the further you go in this
network the more links you traverse the
more bandwidth you need on those links
if you go very short you need less
bandwidth us you need less cables that's
the intuition behind this whole idea and
now the question is well it's basically
written here and what we found is that
we can in order to get to the lower
bound we can improve 50% over factory
and and one-third over the dragonfly so
which means we can make these topologies
at the same performance by a factor of
two less expensive or by a factor of 1/3
less expensive ok so now let me tell you
oh the diameter is again the the path
length so so that's the between any - no
it's the minimum path you want to kind
of shrink the graph that's all well
that's the same solution yeah yeah yeah
sorry I actually put a few slaves you
know this is interchangeable but the
idea is that we want to make sure that
any node can reach any other node in the
network with no more in this case than 2
or 4 intermediate nodes or intermediate
cables ok that's that's the key idea and
let me look at an example so we have an
example that's a full bandwidth Petri
this is in fact a machine that has been
deployed in Japan as a tsubame
to 0 machine that has a three level
factory so this is just a normal fat
tree we have these switches three levels
level 1 level 2 and level 3
ok we have to get the cabling as I
showed before it's I think
24:36 port switches I'm not so sure half
of the cables going down half of the
cables going up very simple topology
this says it is a diameter for topology
we can create a similar similar setting
with a diameter to topology that gives
us 50% less routers and 30% yeah fewer
cables in this particular case the
cables will be slightly longer though
but but fiber the cost of fiber as we
will see in a couple of minutes is
actually not too much for parameter it's
a lot for a transceiver so you pay a lot
overhead per cable because you need two
transceivers but per meter is relatively
cheap okay so let me now explain how we
built this so this was just the the
motivation so far but before we do this
I want to explain you this more bound so
the idea is now well if we now want to
minimize the diameter for a given switch
degree right so we we have a technology
we have a switch that we have
constructed let's say that switch has 15
ports and now we want to build the graph
that connects the maximum number of end
points using let's say diameter - or
diameter 3 that can be constructed with
the 15 port switch ok so there is in
fact an upper bound that's really easy
to prove so I'm going to prove you this
upper bound in the next five minutes
that's called more bound and the idea
here is in graph theoretical terms that
is an upper bound on the number of
vertices in a graph with a given
diameter so maximum minimum path between
any two vertices maximum minimum length
path and a given radix so the maximum
degree but for our purpose we choose the
same degree for every single vertex so
it's a regular graph so and this
movement is very easy to construct
basically say well if we have 0 and
diameter well then we can reach exactly
one node it's pretty clear if the degree
is K well how many more nodes can be
reach in one step well that's obviously
one plus K okay and if we have the
degree the diameter if we allow the
diameter - we can reach as at most each
of those can reach at most k plus one
more right and so on and so now we can
easily show this more bound and it's
it's really the sum where it ranges from
K times the I equals 0 to D minus 1 and
then came
one to di right so that's that's by
construction that's the maximum number
of nodes we can reach in fact that is
not tight the spout is very bound is
very far from tight but it is an upper
bound so this in fact the best known
upper bound for this kind of graph and
looking at these large graphs is a very
interesting theoretical construct so you
can in fact can you get your the graph
named after you so one of the famous
graphs that hits the mobile is the
Peterson graph the other graph I showed
you the Hofmann singleton graph there's
only one other non-trivial graph
I believe it's 57 vertices or something
well there has to be checked that
achieves that more bound that graph has
not been found so if you find it you can
get it named after you know hole there
is actually if you google for the degree
diameter problem this is a very well
known problem in on Wikipedia there's a
page with people's names and their graph
constructions that hit the upper bound
because people do I mean mathematicians
have fun with this they try to really
find the largest possible graph we are
not going to do this because if you look
at this table there is a double
exponential problem to build these
graphs exhaustively and if you look at
this we see that we don't get very far
so we use another construction in order
to build our graph however we can prove
for that construction that it is within
10% of the more bound so you can gain at
most 10% and and if you have done any
engineering 10% this is in the noise so
that's that's fine
so let me tell you a very high-level
picture of how that works how we
construct such a graph and this now
involves first of all gives you a high
level picture and then I give you a
little bit more detailed picture because
there's involved group theory so it's
not totally trivial but it's also not
complicated so we want to build a graph
of diameter - why do we choose diameter
- well first of all diameter 3 we have
done with this graph I showed you before
the Dragonfly graph all the perks
topologies that I am a three graph
because we have groups and we have at
most one hop in the group at most one
intergroup hop and at most one group hop
in the target group so we this is a
diameter 3 graph we have such a
construction for diameter - it's more
complicated because we don't have such
an close to optimal construction
diameter 1 this kind of a useless craft
because diameter 1 means while I have a
single switch in the middle
needs to connect all nodes all right so
that's not going to work because I will
not build a switch for technology
constraints not build a single chip
switch with a hundred thousand endpoints
that's not going to happen
so how does our construction look like
it's based on this mathematical theory
developed here and they call them M&F
MMS graphs based on the the names McKay
Miller in C Ron so we have two identical
groups of routers that will be the
construction so each of these square
dark squares is is a router in the
network or switch again the same
terminology then these switches or
routers form groups so here in this case
it's a five by five so there are five
groups of five nodes each in the left
side and these groups have identical
connections and I will explain you how
these connections come to place in a
couple of minutes on the right side we
have exactly the same but a different
identical connection so we have five
groups each of those is identical but
they have different a different
communication pattern and then this is
still the very high-level picture and
then each of those groups is connected
to the other site but it's connected to
all the groups as you can see it feels a
little bit like a dragonfly and I've
shown you before the the 2d the
two-level fully connected graph so here
each of these groups on the Left graph
is connected to all of the groups on the
right side and vice versa of course so
it's a very high connectivity pattern
okay so let me now explain a little bit
more how to in fact build a real network
like this and it starts like much of
group theory by selecting a prime number
and finding a prime power if you're here
I see some spirit some people smiling
and enjoying group theory so we like we
select the prime power the nice thing is
for computer scientists or engineers to
is a prime number and any power of two
will work to construct such a graph if
you like that we will not use two as an
example but fine and and there is a
theorem that we can show that any prime
power Q can be decomposed into 4w +
Delta so you have to find this
decomposition that is also fine just
just believe it in case you're not
familiar with that theory so it's a very
basic theorem let me build a slim fly
based on this Q on this prime power Q
that we found and this Q is exactly here
so
in the in this case Q equals 5 5 is a
prime number as we know and we get
obviously 5 by 5 twice so 2 2 Q 2 Q
square many routers in that network ok
so that's the graph construction and the
network radix you can you can compute by
using this Delta from up here but then
again we will see in a couple of minutes
once we have picked that prime power we
have to build so called finite field and
again feel like routier you will
immediately relate to this and the idea
of this finite field if if Q is pry in
this easiest case so for example in 5 we
can do this the finite field will just
have all the elements from 0 to Q minus
1 so 0 1 2 3 4 in this case ok with
modular arithmetic modulo 5 in all these
cases ok for example if you look at this
Q equals 5 we get 2 times 5 square
router's so that's 50 network radix will
be 7 and so here is 5 by 5 and the
finite field will go from 0 to 4 very
very simple ok cool so now let's
actually look at how we can label these
routers we will need this later so now
we have these 50 routers here and now we
can arrange them in a very simple
labeling space we can first have for the
Q equals 5 example we can name the left
graph 0 and the right graph 1 ok and
then we can of course introduce this
finite field sub Q times finite fields
up Q right so we name those guys 5 by 5
and it's a very simple three dimensional
naming scheme ok so that's is our
question ok so that's an extremely
simple scheme that we will get back
later to but now once we have found our
final prime power we have constructed
our finite field now there is four
finite for each finite field we can find
a primitive a so-called primitive
element in a finite field so a primitive
element is an element in a finite field
that generates a finite field so that's
again a tiny bit of group Theory so what
they're really thus is that all nonzero
elements of the finite field are cons
can be constructed by taking that
primitive element to some power modulo
the size of the finite field so we can
basically write everything as this eye
to the eye
attack to the I'm sorry so in this case
for five what we can do is we find this
primitive element equals two now the
typical question is how do you find the
primitive element of a finite field yes
we don't know however there is one we
know that there that there is one and
for all the constructions that we have
we have done so far it's really easy to
find by a brute force you just try and
we have a small Python script that finds
this there there are some shortcuts to
finding primitive elements but it
doesn't even this even not even verse
doing it so we just brute force the
thing and that's very simple okay so you
can see because the finite fields say
they don't have to get very large until
we reach two hundred thousand or a
million end points in the network so so
we don't need that large these large
financials you can easily check the two
is a primitive element I don't want to
do it with you because you have to check
every single of those four values here
at for example if you look at well I
mean the this two to the four and what
five is basically the same and it is one
right so two to the four sixteen one
five this one good what we do then and
and this is also very well known in the
field group theory we build the set of
even powers and the set of odd powers
this is the set of even powers the set
of odd powers and again this is a very
mechanical thing you don't need to
understand anything you just apply int
and here we have these two sets X and X
Prime again the even powers this to the
zero to the two and so on and then the
odd powers again once we have these two
fields here in this case it's 1 & 4 & 2
& 3 still very simple we can use these
fields to build the connections for
these groups ok so and this is also a
relatively simple rule so we first look
at this set of the odd powers which
build our connections for subgraph 0 and
the set of the even powers build our
connections for subgraph 1 again if we
go through the example we look at the
routers we look at one of this column
and we look at our set 1 & 4 and now we
check we connect all routers that have a
vertical Manhattan distance of the
element in the set so first we look at
one while we connect every router that
has a distance 1 its
lovely simple and then we look at four
well there's only there only two routers
that have a distance for here which are
at the top at the bottom one and then
we're done
let me do this for all the groups on the
left side we apply to three all the
groups on the right side and we are done
this is our intra-group connection okay
and obviously this is not a real network
we need to connect the groups among each
other as well
so the intergroup connection and there
we have a simple linear rule the two
routers 0 X Y and one MC are connected
if and only if y equals MX plus C so
again a very simple rule to evaluate you
can write a very small script that just
builds these graphs so we have lots of
these scripts and if you look at an
example we take this router 1 0 0 so
here x is 0 Y is 0 and M and CML MNCs
are here M and C is 0 but you can
exchange those and that would connect
this router to all these routers back
here ok if you just pick another example
the 1 1 0 router so that guy would
connect to the diagonal it gets a pretty
it becomes an interesting structure but
that's due to these prime fields so use
finite fields but but make it actually
quite pretty in fact if you look at
those graphs at the end and then I don't
want to do all the examples because it
gets not so pretty if you plot them on a
2d a very small 2d space so it's a very
tightly connected network at the end and
and this construction guarantees and as
I'll get to in a minute that we are all
we only have one intermediate hop from
going from A to B it's a Wiegel and this
construction also guarantees which is
not so easy to show that we are within
10% of the mo bond so that can be proven
but that's nothing for this talk so we
need to talk the radix is this 3 Q minus
4 or something so that's also related to
the prime power you choose so now the
question is now we have built the
network of switches all right so now we
have connected all the switches but of
course switches are kind of useless
without servers so how do we now put
this servers into place and that's a
very simple question how many endpoints
to be attached to each router ok so here
we have a switch we have the cables
going into the network and here we have
the number of endpoints so this is
everything up here is kind of the slim
fly topology everything down here is
just our use of that topology ok and the
rule is relatively simple if we want
full global bandwidth so what was full
global what does for global bandwidth
mean it's basically if we run and
all-to-all steady state which means each
of those nodes on end points down here
injects packets as fast as it can into
the network and addresses those packets
to random end points in the network ok
that's that's the workload we want to
support just random global all to all
communications ok and we want to achieve
that each of those endpoints can do this
at the full line rate as much as this
link supports by the way this link is as
fast as any link and link in the network
so there's a homogeneous link speed
Network in this case ok
so these all of these guys shoot as fast
as they can to all of the nodes and the
rule is relatively simple so here's
again animation and the rule is
relatively simple so we can compute this
I'm slightly running out of time so so
let me just give you the result the idea
is and and you can derive this the
intuition is again that we have do have
an animation for this exactly so that we
put one third of the of the links from
the router that leave the router to
endpoints and 2/3 to the network why is
it 2/3 to the network well remember we
have the distance to network right so
this means these 1/3 they will shoot
into the network and they will leave
they will occupy 1/3 of the outgoing
links right just by shooting into the
network ok but then there are also these
other nodes that need to route through
my router because they have to have an
intermediate hop
and get out again this is again one
third incoming monitored outgoing so
that's the intuition if you have a
diameter three network by the way this
would be one-quarter at the end and so
on I'd if you assume uniform routing and
we will get to the routing we do
actually uniform load balanced routing
in this network okay does that make
sense
and I see people nodding perfect so now
let's do two very simple cost models and
there are two ways to arrange switches
and routers switches and end points in a
network so one is this top of the rack
model that everybody seems to be using
so we have our racks here there is about
a 1 meter distance it gets actually
relevant for the cable length
computation so at 1 meter distance
between those and we can have a
different network or a different layout
but we put all the switches in the
middle of the data center all right so
the interest which links will be very
short but there will be long wires
coming from the sewer from the end
points to the switches in fact this is a
slightly better configuration in most of
the of the cases this is slightly easier
to install and maintain because here the
problem is if you have your large switch
in the middle you need to route all
cables somehow through a real space into
that middle thing and that usually
becomes a total mess well if you do this
you have a nice distribution of your
cables throughout the whole data set if
you don't have the one point of failure
also so usually people like this in
practice this looks better in theory ok
and now of course we have to talk about
the cables at the end if we want to
really define costs at the end so we
have a very simple cable cost model and
here the idea is that we have a length
in meters and the cost dollar per
gigabyte per second right and then we we
look at various cables so Mellanox
cables typically so fiber cables you can
buy on the market in fact this number
comes from Colfax direct so you just
look at an online shop what these cables
cost so they're not representative if
you if you buy it at volume right but
I'll be assuming that they get equally
cheaper so we're assuming that fiber
cables get equally cheaper to copper
cables if you buy at volume what we can
observe is that these are the copper
cables you can already observe they only
go to 7 meters you cannot buy a copper
cable longer than 7 meters ok we still
assume you could write a linear fit the
fiber cables start very high so they're
extremely expensive for short cables
because the transceivers are so
expensive
the cost per meter like remember lengths
here is very low so you can go very far
once you have invested your transceivers
for the fiber cable I'm here at the
transceiver is basically free so only
the cable costs this is the difference
but this is what we use for the later
cost model here we have the exact
numbers here for of the tooth it's the
router cost model is similar because we
need to worry about the different radix
and the cost dollar of the router here
we have some numbers and we see that
there's also somewhat a linear
relationship between the radix of the
switch and the cost of the switch that
is very surprising to me I was expecting
a more like a quadratic relationship
because a crossbar fold by section cross
bar takes quadratic chip space but
somehow that turned out linear in
practice and we used again Mellanox gear
just because we could get this commodity
off-the-shelf pricing if you now look at
these different topologies and I want to
spend too much time on this but the idea
here is we have the number of end points
at this axis so in thousands up to
50,000 nodes in the network yes so there
are two answers to this so first of all
we don't directly consider it because
it's extremely hard to assess what that
means so so my favorite story here is
that that I was actually I was helping
to construct a blue water system at NCSA
which was the largest academic
supercomputer so five hundred million
dollar project at the time went online
2012 was a 3d torus you would assume
that's a very simple topology to cable
and and I was helping to design the
network at that time or helping to also
do performance analysis and then I
thought okay let's let's actually walk
into the room and cable one of those
racks I went there I have no physical
abilities of my own right but I still
try to cable one of those racks and it
looked like a total mess even for 3d
tours what is the reason for this
because the 3d torus you have to arrange
it in kind of a 2d space but you also
have to make sure that these wraparound
links don't get very long so what you do
is you fold it and at the end once
you've done all this folding and there's
arranging in the 2d space the cabling
doesn't look very regular anymore at
least not to my limited ability of
assessing it so in fact I would
conjecture that even the more
complicated topology
would not look much more complicated if
you wire it because at the end what you
do when you wire these are what I did
the particular cry setup is you have
your table your sheet of paper there's
numbers on it
and then you take the numbered cable
into the number port here and then I
have to make sure that it goes into the
other number port down there
I would assume we could do the same it's
just that the numbering would be a
different permutation of those numbers
so I would not be too worried about that
even though I have very limited
experience with this I have to say the
second question is I'm actually not a
big fan of read numb or rewiring so you
mentioned what what happens if these
cables fail let them fail so we will get
to this I'm a big fan of fail in place
networking because you cannot pull a
cable anyway like if you have if you
have cable lying in a fiber cable lying
in into a in a cable enclosure and our
cable anchors even for the Bluewater
system were like this thing for the for
the perk system that we were planning
they would have thing like this okay it
was a completely crazy system and there
never I don't know 100 kilometers of
cable or so suppose the the deal for
that system but you don't worry about it
if you put them in and the idea for that
for these systems was actually just
throw a new cable over the old ones but
most topologies actually degrade
gracefully
torus does not but dragonfly dust and
slim fly to us as we will see in a
minute so which means if a cable fails
are the routing will fix it no worries
as long as not more than 10 percent of
your cables fail you will not lose more
than 10 percent of your bandwidth and in
fact it even degrades gracefully
afterwards so if you lose 20 percent of
your cables you lose 20 percent of your
endless the question is now well when do
these things disconnect when do you
actually have a note that you cannot
physically reach anymore because too
many cables fail there will be a slide
on this in two minutes let me just
finish the cost argument um and the cost
is just purely the cost of equipment the
cost of the cables as I showed you the
cost model and the switches right so
nothing else not no installation nothing
and here we see that it gets in these
these just to pick out one the factory
here
slim fly is of course the cheapest one
dragonfly is slightly more expensive so
there is this factor of 2 here typically
and the factor of 1 third here and then
you could look at tourist tours is even
more expensive so
but this is something to look at with
more time just believe me it's the
cheapest Network and the more bound
would be slightly below here like 10% or
so okay oh this is this is why I showed
you the data center layout picture so
this guy here yeah one meter here we
assume that there is one meter interact
distance if you actually look at this
paper you get a much more detailed
description of like the enclosure size
and everything we assume so we really
model the full data center setting and
that makes it rather complex in fact you
to get all the routings and even the
layout is non-trivial but but that's all
described in the paper so let's just
look at a case study let's assume we
want to build a network with 10,000
endpoints which in the slim fly would
get us radix necessary radix of 43 and
would get us 720 switches with 10,000
endpoints I I find this pretty cool
actually a very small number of switches
if you look at this if we keep the radix
constant we could build these different
networks like factory random topology is
flatten butterfly dragonfly and we would
see that they would all be much more
expensive in terms of power per node and
cost per node and slim fly image just
looks this this is always smaller here
and if you say this is unfair because we
fix the radix and we get slightly number
different numbers of end points we can
also fix the number of end points here
and have a variable radix by the way all
these other topologies we drive into the
optimum for their setting so we say we
want to build the optimal flattened
butterfly Network and we just pick the
right ratings for this right and if you
do this then then we again we get about
20% cheaper in terms of energy and well
30% cheaper with the best competitor in
terms of of cost okay
very good now this resilience question
that we had on night you didn't really
ask that question but it's kind of
related can we just have this Network
degrade randomly and the idea here is we
look at a fully connect Network and we
check what happens if we remove links
like random random links a lot of
Montecarlo simulation studies we do this
for all these networks and I don't have
enough time to go through this because
I'm already slightly over time but the
the percentages you see here this is
really how many how much how many
cent of the number of links you have to
remove before the network becomes
disconnected meaning one node is not
reachable anymore in the network and you
can see with a fat tree that's about 35%
for small tourists this really bad
actually goes down if you have more more
no it's because it's really to the easy
to disconnect one guy in the corner
while for random topologies and slim fly
random is expected to be very good
because cables are just like randomly
anyway and slim fly it's about as good
as random better than dragonfly and
better than flatten butterfly very
unexpected as well as it's one of those
results look at all but actually it
makes sense graph theoretically and we
can talk about this offline no we didn't
do this but it behaves similarly I would
strongly suspect so so we didn't look at
node fear there's only a cable failures
old link failures ok so so then we could
talk about routing but let me skip this
in the interest of time because again
you can use the Galois field theory that
I explained earlier to Rao it and now
let me get to the last result I want to
show you this is actually real
simulations for that network just did I
just say real simulation stuff ok so so
we didn't actually build a physical
Network we could because we don't have
that much money but we use the simulator
that was developed by by Professor deli
and students at Stanford to show the
utility of the dragonfly topology we
took the same simulator and ported it to
slim fly and here are some simulation
results with that exact same simulator
so it's not our simulator that's what I
want to say and it's a it's a real
setting and how does this work so this
again slightly if you're not used to
looking at these networking plots let me
explain this so we have a latency this
is basically we have an all-too all
pattern right as I mentioned earlier
every node injects packets into the
network that have a random destination
node and they are routed through the
network according to the routing
strategies that I will talk about in a
minute ok well they will get somehow get
to the destination here we say well what
if we send zero packets per second ok
that's not that is close to zero of
course we if you send 0 them you get
nothing but close to zero and here is
what if we send as fast as the link
supports right so zero offered load
until one offered load ideally and and
then the latency here right so what
happens if you push data into a network
all of those plots are very
characteristic they start at the latency
this is the lowest is basically your
diameter of the network you can see slim
fly is always best in terms of latency
because the diameter is lowest all right
so these this thing here slim fly it
with minimum routing this is slim fly
with another routing this is fat tree up
here and then it's dragonfly here and
you see slim fly diameter - dragonfly
diameter three fat tree diameter four so
you can see this here very clearly right
if you have no loads well the network is
empty and now assume if we increase the
load and it's like in real traffic on a
real street we increase the injection of
cars into a network remember it's a
lossless Network
so like cars packets don't get lost and
at some point there will be a traffic
jam in the network all right some point
the network will be just be clocked up
this is when this goes to infinity so
this means your network stops
essentially all of these go to infinity
then none of those goes to 100% because
routing is not ideal what we can see
here the question is now well how how
does it behave for this is going to
infinity so dragonfly doesn't fare all
that well that's because routing is very
complicated on your dragonfly here we
see that tree is the best one actually
fat tree has the latest going to
infinity which means it has the highest
bandwidth but also twice the cost but if
you see this distance here it's only
like five percent more so it's again one
of those things well do I want to pay
twice as much for five percent more
bandwidth maybe not and then we have the
slim fly which is here very close the
next contender for the fat tree
okay so these are the networks and then
I could show you a large number of other
plots that you can find in the paper and
I guess that's probably not appropriate
here and I want to wrap up briefly with
a couple of takeaway messages so first
takeaway message is that we now have a
lowest diameter topology in the sense
that we now prove the mobile and it's
going to be very hard at all impossible
to improve upon the cost of this
topology because well it's the
theoretical bound that we cannot make
much better and it is resilient we have
it's very cost and power effective 25%
of a dragonfly in 20 and 26% in terms of
power and it gives you the lowest
latency because diameter - right
gives you a full global bandwidth and
then we have lots of results for this
and one last thing I wanted to mention
you can actually use that same topology
to build a network on chip yes exactly
the same very nice properties but of
course in a different setting because
network on chips have different
parameters they don't have fiber
connections for example but we did this
this appear this year at us plus but
it's basically the same construction a
slightly different layout because that
we need to lay it out in a 2d book graph
style topology so limited number of
layers but this works really really well
under network on shape as well and we
assume that there are many different
other uses for this so with that I would
like to thank you for your attention and
I am open for questions any questions
that have been asked during the talk yes
do you have any intuition why you're
making that crap so yes but it took us a
while to develop that intuition why we
do this eventually it is it is really a
graph theoretical problem that you want
to solve and the nice piece is that this
problem this degree diameter problem you
should really Google for it it's very
interesting for the theoretical
mathematicians so it has been quite some
work on this and the the idea why we go
through these finite fields is or why
they go through these finite fields this
we need to to build the graph with the
maximum girth
so the girth is the the length of the
shortest of the of the circle shortest
length of the so if you want to maximize
this because you want to distribute the
data as much as possible as quickly as
possible to as many nodes if you have
many short circles I mean even or
trivial circles right then this is not
suitable to well so that's kind of my
intuition that I developed over time and
you could also look at Rama Neutron
graphs and their other graph classes
that that are that don't only work for
diameter too but they're further away
from the mobile and so for diameter two
we are very lucky that we have this one
construction that gets us very very
close for the others larger one larger
diameters we don't
but for larger diameter we have
different topologies that we could use
so I mean that that space is covered
well the questions yes yes I skip the
routing slide but but you can actually
use the same that by construction you
know where the cables on and by
construction you can find the shortest
path from any in this three-dimensional
space that I lined out you can find
which node to hop to and where to go to
the final destination but that's not all
routing is slightly more complicated you
cannot really employ a shortest path
routing on this topology to skip this
for full-time reason well you can okay
so let me be more precise you can apply
shortest path routing where you just
draw it along the shortest path which is
always of diameter too right
but if you do this then I can give you a
traffic pattern where you will look
really bad so I will I will just give
you I will just choose some nodes and I
will create a congestion that is of the
order of K all right so if K is your
degree and this is really easy to
construct actually so it's not too hard
so if you don't want to run into this
problem what you have to do is you have
to employ adaptive routing so you have
to somehow check well how busy is my
next link and if that link is very busy
because already too many of you have too
many
endpoints or sending on to that link I'm
sending it along a non minimal path
right so and this is in the results I
skip this full-time reasons but so here
we have different routing so this is
minimum routing and this is what I just
said there's no adaptivity I'm not
looking at the where at the state of the
network so it's completely oblivious
then we have a body and routing which is
also oblivious but what valiant routing
does is it picks a random other node we
are routing through this random other
node and then this random other node
runs through the destination it doesn't
do too well because we're losing half
the bandwidth you can also see that it's
asymptotically of preaching and
approaching 50% because we now double
the path length okay but that's one of
these things and then we can use this
you gal routing which was also developed
at Stanford which gives us there are two
different variants here no
this L which gives us a very good result
as well and you gal is now a uniform
uniform global adaptive and this L is is
for local uniformly global adaptive load
balanced that local there is a global
one as well
local only assumes local knowledge of
the switch global is kind of
unreasonable because it assumes that you
know all the other switches states in
the network when making a routing
decision which of course you don't but
they use this in the thesis of the if
the student just to get the upper bound
I mean what if we would know this is
what we didn't consider it so this is
the adaptive routing that we would
suggest using for a slim fly in fact the
very similar routing is necessary for
dragonfly so and and dragonfly just you
this is why we only have one result your
dragonfly by default uses that routing
any my conjecture would be that any low
diameter topology that is cost-effective
will need
adaptive routing right fat tree kind of
also needs it but you can get around it
becomes most InfiniBand that for its
factory or routed statically what do you
typically have is you how you have a
table you look at your output queue
length so you so you look at what's
what's the traffic jam into that
direction if it's too much then I have a
have secondary and tertiary options
where I just move to next one check if
that's too long and if that's too long
then I go to the next one and so on and
they're biased oh yeah they're about
five papers how to optimize this for
slim fly by Spanish a Spanish group that
has specialized on routing so so we have
just used the standard routing but
they're actually building a real
technology out of this it's not also not
so trivial because again you need to
have all these tricks how to actually
get your packets through their network
then there's also a virtual channel a
question how many virtual channels do
you need that you don't have deadlock so
so this much more complicated that that
I could explain in these in this forty
minute talk but actually quite many
other groups have invested read
heavily into into making a slim fly of
Arc so we now understand fully how to
build it so that's and there is at least
there at least two companies that are
very seriously looking into building it
the problem is I saying that I'm not
allowed to talk about those companies so
but but there is very high interest
because we now really understand it and
if you have a router for dragonfly which
we do right there's a company that
builds a router for dragonfly the same
router will work for there's some minor
modifications for some time because the
dragonfly already needs adaptive routing
so some play is not more complicated it
needs different directions but that's
all technologies the same well now the
question is how much compute do you
actually need in order to to build a
quantum computer if you can have that
compute on a single and a single chip
then you probably don't need it well
even even though the the unship version
of that thing you could need because you
would still route among multiple
elements but what now if that compute
for example for quantum error correction
which can be arbitrarily expensive as we
know depending on what exact scheme you
use and then how long the coherence time
should be
we may need much more compute than this
and then you would build a larger scale
system out of those guys and actually it
doesn't only get good for larger scale
it also begins to kick in with like 4050
endpoints so for example here the
network on chip topology that we design
that starts with a design for 100 tiles
on the chip and we get best performance
for 1000 but
and that that's what I always wanted to
discuss exactly can you use this for for
teleportation networks or for swap
networks but there it seems that that
these that these swap networks do they
need physical yes exactly
correct once we fully understand what
the properties of the two bits are then
then that we could look into this if
this makes sense and I believe this
would actually make sense because this
this graph class is extremely powerful
not using the technology but but just
using the graph class and applying into
the same problem yeah I believe that
would be a very good thing to look into
once once we understand their properties
[Applause]